l a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
nella bat caverna ragazzi non chiedetemi
come ci siamo finiti qui dentro ma vabbè
siamo su scrive lazzarini si ribella zam
est
sto sbagliando tutto siamo su scrive
lazzaroni massino scorso episodio che
aveva massacrato di botte joker e siamo
finiti nella nella bat caverna in poche
parole dobbiamo andare avanti da qua eh
vabbè comunque praticamente ragazzi devo
andare a salvare tutti gli eroi di del
mondo dei fumetti e questo dovrebbe
essere il mondo di super noi che mi
dicono a metropolis perfetto andiamo a
salvare più la superman perché combatte
non abbiamo già finito dovrebbe essere
da qualche parte qui va bè ragazzi non
solo le sesto arnaldo lex luthor ma noi
andiamo qui sotto perfetto noi siamo
cioè flash sovrappeso perché poiché il
giotto ti sei mangiato piccola fa ancora
tula mi tocchi capito ragazzi non so
perché flash mi sta attaccando ma penso
che una banana possa risolvere tutto
[ __ ] è magnate questa non si è
fatto un call a banana e qui a terra
razza di scimmia troppo evoluta che
cazzo fa l'aveva affanculo esso di
picchio è che a casa ma vince versus
press ragazzo mi sto facendo il culo di
brutto meglio che scappo togliti dalle
chat su flash sovrappeso [ __ ] sa
oppure caduto da wijsmans tra trincia
trincerò sta funzionando mai così lai
schiaccia loved by così vai così ne così
si ragazzo è morto flash bene così
lavorare di tutto questo è che se
tentate di attaccare fa vj finita
malissimo max stiamo ricevendo nuovi
allarmi sei pronto a procedere agli
ordini e ai quattro siti sta succedendo
qualcosa di sospetto vai così ragazzi
super fa vige in azione siamo siamo
pronti cosa devo fare nessun altro
desiderio finché non ottengo il mio
voglio un amico cioè questo che devo
fare è senti alibaba ma io non sono un
fabbricatore di amici così a domicilio
comunque genio della lam
non ce la farò prima o poi ragazzi non
ci fosse genio della limpida genio
debole genio persona se senti e va bene
lui il primo desiderio ce l'ha preso
senti io ti volevo creare un certo tipo
di genio ma va bene così il mio anello è
stato rubato via iniziate l'ho ripreso
facevano così vuoi sposarmi questa è la
mia richiesta di matrimonio no vabbè è
no ai malati incazzare stanno scherzando
cioè tieni pieni pieni perfetto camicie
ma che cazzo fate vi statale andò per
picchiarmi
ma io ti ho dato una mappa 6 [ __ ]
allora ragazzi cè un cazzo di tizio che
scappa invisibile cos'è mi serve
qualcosa qui legare il mio titano a che
cazzo non è di un titano fammi capire
vabbè zio speriamo che funzioni perché
non ne ho idea questo dovrebbe bastare
perfetto si mettono solo minuto di donne
basca with click che il cazzo uscito una
cosa fa cioè ragazzi non è bastato che
io non c'entro il cazzo è io ci ho
provato ha detto che andava bene quindi
non voglio sentire lamentele ma per lo
stesso superman versus lex luthor che
cazzo ed e ribelli planet perfetto
ragazzi è vicina a delhi planet si ode
un grido d'aiuto maxwell ragazzi siamo
con superman uno degli esperimenti di
lex luthor un cyborg un cyborg in nome
metallo ha preso in ostaggio lois lane e
jimmy olsen dal daily planet dovrei
attivare il metallo fuori dall'edificio
in modo che io faccio in tempo a salvare
il noise e jimmy dobbiamo prenderlo vivo
così potrai interrogarlo va ai ragazzi
ci siamo aiutiamo clark kent ovvero
superman
vieni a prendermi sotto choc la vj alla
riscossa che calzano piano piano piano
zio ragazzo mi sto attaccando di brutto
e non so cosa devo ballo rado tirano
fuori come cazzola tiro fuori
devo ok ci sono ci sono aereo aereo ok
ragazzi non provateci a casa io ci provo
fermo no non riesco a legarlo aspetta un
attimo ci posso riuscire prima o poi fai
così lega vieni brutto as.tro vieni
fuori che ti porto via a cosa fa ragazze
ce l'ho fatta se ottimo lavoro marzo
grazie superman non c'è di che ora siete
al sicuro grazie a maxwell
no veramente grazie a fa vj ma non
importa già vedo il titolo può vincere
il mito super pensato alla grande le
porte a da qualcosa ovviamente sono
stato io brutta stronza marzo e quassù
cosa che succede cioè allegato allegato
tizio perché c'è un elicottero va bene
ogni porta ragazzi ci siamo cosa devo
fare
ci sarà superman e userò la vista la
jeep per dare un'occhiata da vicino da
vicino a cosa pazienza lex sed lex
luthor e c'è anche dopo il game che
cazzo farlo non temere marzo e posso
occuparmi di luthor e io penserò ad hoc
manager ragazzi diventa fantastico e
cos'è un transformer lo voglio io subito
cioè non ci voglio neanche pensare le
volte se ma io non posso andare in giro
con un aereo di linea cioè capiamoci
vabbè io scusate se non ho bussato ma un
aereo di linea da parcheggiare devi
imparare le buone maniere ti mostrerò
cos'è la vera forza farlo dopo il ginger
cosa fa
cazzo succede ora superman mio avvio gli
abbia dato i superpoteri
ora non mi serve l'abito cazzo fa oddio
lo ha preso anche un tratto distrugge
proprio le mie stesse mani alieno ma
karmiche questo mi sembra un incontro
libres l'ing cosa fa superman ha preso
tutto zio bieco le scommesse rai che a
superman tra quotato 1x o maggior alfred
e io abbiamo un piano ma è rischioso
mentre super meno vicino a te appiccica
gli eau materiali che lo renda
resistenti alle radiazioni
ma che cazzo è un materiale che lo rende
resistente alle radiazioni
allora costume in piombo c'era gatto non
penso che sta roba vada bene che cazzo
creato
ecco cos'è questo ragazzi sono l'uomo di
latta non si sa come cazzo
vabbè dei vent'anni niente io mi sta
incamminando ragazzi faccio prima a
farlo invincibile perché se non ce la
faccio
ti sei solo reso più lento ma che dici
di o chi è che il mio ragazzi
ricordatevi che sta raccontato superman
no adesso con marzo affinché non tornò
va beh io sono l'uomo di latta non più
maxwell mi lanciano addosso no brutto
stronzo vuoi metterti contro l'uomo di
latta raga sono sono più forte di te
amico mio tu non mi conosci
l'uomo di latta sconfigge tutti ragazze
sta diventando brutta la situazione qui
sto facendo fuori t rex a mani nude che
manco bear grylls mai così
ragazzi si nota ancora ma basta la
quantizzazione crea aquila cavalcabile
spara bombelli non si sa perché sparuta
pompei polposi che cazzo è sesto a merda
sa sacro ma che cazzo ma che cazzo ma
perché ma perché sta cavalcando un
uccello che le dimensioni di un tic tac
ragazzi ma che cazzo succede
vabbè io io non ho parole su questo ma
detto questo è il videogioco più idiota
che abbia mai giocato in vita mia che va
a farsi beffa io e il mio pc ti faremo
il culo cioè ragazzi mi sembra di
avergli insegnato volo a pj vi sono io
non so veramente parole si brutto
bastardo se la brava a sfidare la mia
cazzo di aquila non puoi ragazzi io e la
mia pila siamo troppo forti cioè io da
adesso in avanti sono alla mia password
a proposito poi genscher come hai fatto
ad arrivare qui non ricordi maxwell
cosa dovrei ricordare la pagina che è
strappato e poi usato per andare a
gotham all'inizio non contro nasti se
sul retro c'era scritto qualcosa vero ha
scritto qualcosa lui non lo so questo è
ancora che si vedono ma basta ora
maxwell dai a supermike cosa che sia
fatto di kryptonite per metterlo al
tappeto next spada di kriptonite cripto
nemica ci voleva laura per scrivere sta
roba vai vai sub giustizia che cos'è
fallo no ragazzi sta morendo io sono
sempre sul mio piccione ha redditi
luthor costituisciti la battaglia è
finita ragazzi siamo salvatori della
legge no non è ancora finita ti sbagli
luthor stato sconfitto aspetta posso
vincere ragazzi è un ambiente che li
siete accorti ma io ho un grandissimo
uccello sotto le gambe non è una frase a
doppio senso tutto deve aver messo uno
strike qui dove se no mai
non lo so però io il mio piccione lo
troveremo
c'è un solo post hicks ufficio nel quale
non possiamo guardare lì lì dentro la
casa forte ii mio dio io lo aprirò col
piccione grande superman no vabbè marco
il piccione ci sarei riuscito uguale
cioè non credete vi ragazzi abbiamo ci
consoli al traguardo
e fantastico fare missioni così sì ma
non ce l'ho presa ma non funziona che
cazzo cazzo salvarlo perfetto non mi
stava prendendo male bene ragazzi io e
il mio la mia mascotte che in qualche
modo la chiamerò penso billy è siamo
così potente da poter conquistare il
mondo ragazzi che cazzo è quello sì va
beh lo prendono a schiaffi per strada ci
penso io abito civile senza attrezzatura
estinto per un motivo no vabbè reja sta
succedendo di tutto perché sto
cavalcando un tizio perché son diventato
grigio ragazzi la mia aquila si è
trasformata in un tizio con la barba
comunque io io direi che per questo
episodio posso concludere qui perché sta
succedendo un disastro anche ragazzi
prima di finire episodio devo provare a
fare una cosa che mi avete chiesto tutti
che è questa
e lui ragazzi cercherà jack sparso
fatemelo cavalcare vi prego no non posso
cavalcarlo perché sto già cavalcando
nuovo barbuto comunque potete vedere che
jack sparrow
no no perché sto attaccando c'è spazio a
fermo uomo barbuto
io no jack non sono io ti giuro è lui è
lui che sta facendo tutto non sono io
perdonami ragazzi molto jack
vabbè tornerà nei prossimi episodi vero
non se la sia presa perché non ho fatto
un cazzo fa tutto lui è comunque a sei
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciate
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come noi videocrate nella
descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi non ci
vediamo al prossimo video ragazzi